there is more money here
than we could spend
in 10 lifetimes i certainly can't
launder it
that's pretty realistic too you're gonna
have to have a lot of small businesses
to run through millions of dollars hi
i'm jerry williams and i was a special
agent with the fbi for 26 years i
investigated economic crime financial
fraud i'm also the author of fbi myths
and misconceptions a manual for armchair
detectives today we're going to look at
money laundering clips and movies and
judge how realistic they are
money laundering 101
say you come across a suitcase with 5
million bucks in it what would you buy
a yacht
a mansion
a sports car now his money laundering
101 is
a little right but he has some things
that are wrong the irs won't let you buy
anything of value with it the irs will
let you spend as much money as you have
but they want to know
where you got it from
and they also want to make sure that
they get their cut so if a criminal or a
bad guy goes in and wants to lay down
you know a million dollars for a home
that is going to be reported to the irs
i think it's called form
8300 and if they're suspicious about the
activity it's also going to be reported
to fenson
you gotta age it up crumple it drag it
through the dirt you don't need to run
it through a washing machine but i guess
if a criminal has some illegal source of
money and it's coming in brand new crisp
bills and he's trying to
you know pretend that it's part of his
normal revenue from a business i guess
he would want to make it look like it
has been handled but i've never heard of
that before next
you need a cash business this clip is
very realistic strip clubs and casinos
restaurants and bars any type of
business where cash is being used and
transacted are just the perfect kind of
businesses to do money laundering that
mixture goes from an american bank
to a bank from any country that doesn't
have to listen to the irs
it then goes into a standard checking
account
and voila
all you need is access to one of over
three million terminals
because your work is done
well your work is done once the money is
in the banking system doesn't need to be
sent anywhere else it's now you know
clean legitimate money the only thing
that he doesn't talk about is the fact
that when you deposit that money if it's
over ten thousand dollars
you have to fill out what is called a
ctr or a currency transaction report and
this is required of any bank and of
course on that form you have to indicate
where the money came from i would give
this clip about a seven out of ten
i think they got a lot of it right about
the general basic part of money
laundering and gotcha had the most
successful emerald mine of all time
he would inject bad stones with oil to
make them shiny and have his friends in
miami by the emeralds with drug money
and give them as gifts to hookers in
town and this is another example of
money laundering if no one is looking to
to put a value on
those
gems or diamonds or whatever that you're
exchanging for cash to legitimize your
illegal funds then you know on paper it
appears that a legal transaction
has occurred
and that's what they did
this is very realistic and it's based on
the truth drug dealers uh in
south america
yeah are you know did get to a point
where they had so much money
that they buried it rumor is you know
that that that money is still buried
someplace and people are constantly
searching
to find it they hid in cowlettas hiding
places and walls and seedlings
i was involved in a
search once all of the cash was hidden
in the floorboard of the van it was
pretty exciting to come across thousands
and thousands of dollars although
tedious to have to count i would give
this clip a 10 out of 10.
it's pretty authentic there's been
nobody that i'm aware of that has hidden
as much you know cash as escobar has and
uh he's legendary i didn't know what
else to do i tried weighing it
i figured
one bill of any denomination weighs a
gram there are 454 grams to a pound
money is handled on a regular basis
especially in drug dealing and so all of
that is going to
make the
each particular bill weigh differently
than it did when it was a nice crisp
clean fresh bill so there's really no
way of determining how much money is
there just by weighing it i just stack
it up
keep it dry spray it for silver fish
most of the time the money is just
stored in a bag i have heard so many
times about
drug dealers are you know criminals who
have
gathered money together and stored it in
a place only to come back later to find
out that it's water damaged that it's
rotting away that it's been eaten by
animals are insects there is more money
here
than we could spend
in 10 lifetimes i certainly can't
launder it
not with a hundred car washes that's
pretty realistic too you're gonna have
to have a lot of small businesses to run
through millions of dollars i think i'd
give it a 10 out of 10. i think it's
pretty realistic the issue of having too
much money to spend and the way it's
being stored where does this check go
one down a real tickle this is the point
where the money laundering occurs it
turns into money laundering running it
through
a realty company and so this is a pretty
authentic part of the scene i have heard
of many
businesses that have been used to as
front for criminal activity and it's
kind of sweet and funny that many of
them use the names of their
spouses their wives or their children
it's kind of sweet until
the
federal government comes in and and
turn around
let your undercover agent
or your informant
get out of the scene before you come and
make an arrest there is no rush you know
the money's there you know the
transaction's been made you have the
camera the video of everything put him
up against the wall you're under arrest
for violation of the rico statue so he
mentions rico here rico is the
racketeering influence corrupt
organization act
and it is used when you are
investigating a large organization you
see that eye there on the clock
say hi honey i think they could have
done a better job
of disguising it i would wonder if there
was a camera being poked out of this
clock most of the time i have hidden
audio equipment on the cooperating
witness are the undercover agents person
you know a beeper or a cell phone are in
a
a book many times lamps are used just
because they're at the right height and
they're very effective tools for
hidden cameras i would rate it about a
seven or eight i think it's pretty
realistic
when it comes to
the
exchange of funds you know i have
problems with the fact that they're
sitting there counting the money you
know for hours on end
let me ask you something
what about her family
right
how would anybody think they're going to
get through
the
the security system at most airports
with money like that strapped all over
their
body before we became much more security
conscious uh here in the united states
anyway the tsa you know i would still
think would have caught that nowadays
you're going to have to go through a
body scanner as well as all your
carry-on luggage i mean they all got
swiss passports right the woman and her
family are what we would call money
mules people that are being paid to
transfer illegal sums a money mule can
also be paid just to open up bank
accounts and then make those deposits
and transfers in their own name on
behalf of the criminal it's very common
that a criminal will ask a family member
or a friend to do this but they can also
just pay you know a stranger i mean
she's got parents she's got a brother
right brother's got a wife last five
[ __ ] people six seven trips boom
one of the things that really bothers me
about this scene is that i know this
particular case that this movie is made
about
and it was an investment fraud the money
was already in the banking system so i'm
not even sure where all this cash came
from it was not a cash business i hope
this is a scene that is set for comedy
because it's pure comedy there are parts
of the whole movie that are pretty good
i mean it it is based on a real case but
these scenes
not good at all i would rate it as low
as a one or a two
i can confirm that he left sweden on a
private jet with landed in paris last
week
transferring funds from an account that
she doesn't own into her own account
this is what people think about when
they think about money laundering but in
fact it's not money laundering it's
identity fraud it's wire fraud it's
embezzlement i have a number of accounts
at bank of kronfield cayman ireland i'd
like to transfer those accounts and
convert them to bonds naturally you have
the clearing codes naturally
how many accounts will be transferring
30.
because of digital fingerprinting and
facial recognition i think it's becoming
harder and harder to do identity fraud
through
disguises so you know she's getting away
with this but
the
documentation her passport and other and
other types of identification must be
able to be verified
now it's money laundering because she
has taken funds
and she has disguised and concealed them
she's taken money that was uh in
the banking system and she's transferred
those funds and converted them into
bonds
uh
how many of these would you like to
convert for deposit all 50 into five
accounts
these counterfeit bonds i i assume
they're counterfeit to a swiss banker so
they're going to have to have the
appropriate weight and the appropriate
stamps and the appropriate official
markings that
these type of bonds would normally have
and it is a criminal act of the banker
if they do not verify the identity of
the person or if they believe
that those funds were part of a criminal
activity the banker would not accept
those funds and the bank because doing
so
would also be a criminal act the things
that you hear about swiss bank secrecy
has to do
with once those funds have been
legitimately deposited but banking in
switzerland still works just like any
other bank
around the world they still want to know
who you are i think that i would give it
probably a 10 out of 10. you know the
drill everybody gets a burn bag into it
you put anything with barry seals face
or name on it
come on boys we gotta move i can tell
you watching this just makes me so happy
there are some agents in the fbi who
would rather poke their eyes out with a
stick
than to have to go through documents and
papers of course now a lot of this stuff
is going to be online this still goes on
but it's a lot easier i would imagine
to destroy evidence that's online than
it is you know boxes and boxes of paper
like this
back away from the truck with your hands
in the air i have been in many
situations especially during searches
where we come in and identify ourselves
and immediately have to tell people to
stop
stop
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
oh you're going through
guns out okay
now if this particular case happened
before the late 1980s maybe something
like this could happen
but it doesn't happen anymore not since
they created what is called haida so
that they can
deconflict or prevent
all of those agencies coming up on the
same type of case together you don't
want to have any law enforcement agency
or law enforcement officer or agent
harmed because of friendly fire so i
would rate this movie clip about a five
the last half when we had all of these
law enforcement agencies converging at
the same time
no that's not very realistic a last
minute
addition to your catalogue lot number
277a
oil on canvas signed by the artist
the road to damascus by jonathan grazios
this part of the clip is is pretty funny
art is in the eyes of the beholder and
it's harder for
authorities to be able to determine what
is the value of art and unlike other
businesses the art dealer does not have
to complete
that uh ctr like we talked about to let
the irs know that this transaction has
been made 50 000 anyone no no well too
bad then money laundering doesn't
usually occur at an auction like this
each art
and an auction would have the provenance
where you know exactly
who is the artist how much this work of
art has sold for before it has a trail
of how much it's worth how much it's
been valued in the past
we have 50 000 dogs when you have a
single purchaser then that again is when
the radar goes off that this might be in
a suspicious uh activity here quite a
painting you have for yourself sir thank
you somebody at that level should be
suspicious
that a painting of that quality would
sell for this amount
now he's part of the conspiracy and so
uh
if i were able to give him any advice i
tell him this is the point where he
needs to come clean to the fbi i would
rate this scene about a seven or an
eight i think they've got a lot of the
things right about using art and a money
laundering scheme thanks for watching if
you enjoyed this video why not check out
the video above